I like Gavin a lot now I hope he runs
for president here's Bill Maher this is
from his show about a week ago
complaining about Newsom right and he
lives in California he dealt with all
the destruction uh complaining about
Newsom and then uh saying that he should
be president
my other question about this is why
doesn't the governor of the state of
this of the State of California which
this is a very big business in this is
entertainment we're like what cars are
to Detroit why doesn't he or were
Jawbone
you know Jawbone when presidents get the
leaders of Industries who are at odds in
a room and cracked their heads together
and you're running for president why
would you want to alienate the money or
the most important voices oh now you've
opened an interesting can of worms Mr
Gaffigan so first of all you think doubt
Gavin Newsom is running for president
I think he is uh the likely alternative
that's interesting because I remember I
like Gavin a lot now I hope he runs your
present because I think
getting to the National stage would help
with the one thing I have a trouble of
trouble with him about which is
sometimes he's way too
Google
woke left you know the
California well she was it was the
mayor of San Francisco right yeah
yeah
you're making me do you're making me do
this what are you talking about Gavin
Newsom was the mayor of San Francisco
San Francisco is a third world country
there are drugs and crime everywhere you
guys know it we could have showed you
some b-roll of anything over the weekend
of just zombie apocalypse Gavin Newsom
style in San Francisco he then exported
that to California a million people have
left California in the last three years
uh Los Angeles San Francisco all the big
cities crumbling there's a massive
problem related to the cities and the
northern part of California where they
have the actual resources the farms and
the water there's a fight about that
none of it makes any sense there's you
know obviously crime and homeless is
like the easy part but there's just like
an actual cultural rot and everything
else I like Gavin and I hope he runs for
president
I I will keep trying with you Bill but
what is going on here what yeah maybe
you guys see see the weakness there that
I'm trying to just push him over the
edge on and I I just I'll keep trying
but his one criticism is that he's too
woke I mean he's literally about to sign
a bill that will allow the state to take
away parent children from parents
because they don't affirm which they
actually by a firm they mean unaffirm
their child's uh gender it's it's really
just nuts